ok jetzt hat sie jetzt leute feiner find
ich hab noch nie eine 64er runde
gewonnen komposch die das bmbf wieder
aussieht
der bericht
zeuskids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer 64er runde des survival games nach
langer zeit mal wieder oder überhaupt
mal ich weiß gar nicht ob ich weinen
gebracht habe mitarbeiter dennis trane
leica wurde ist und die rechts während
place warum luthe man bei so einem app
die mitte
habt ihr ja ohne scheiß egal wo sie sind
als ich würde sagen ausschwärmen und
dann gleich wieder der mitte treffen
oder sie machen wir gleich wieder
treffen
denn es stimmt mir am anfang doch noch
comeback systems von ganz schnell warum
warum sie haben keine waffen wir können
nicht helfen und keine waffen rüstung
aber keine waffen
wir haben wieder wirst du noch waffen
warum gibts ja ohne scheiß was dieser
wertung weiter
ich schlage dich niemals ohne kaka alter
noch gut warum finde ich nur essen leute
ich will doch nur eine waffe weg laufen
das ist echt spannend der bekannte bock
hilfe ohne scheiß ich will doch einfach
nur wow
was wird er tun war veraltet okay ich
hab das einfach wie kann der sohn
equipment habe ich habe nichts ich habe
gar nichts ich habe nur essen
ich habe erst an keine waffe keine
rüstung der kommt also pr.de
hiermit sei hier der alter was da los
nach samen lange kann ich bei samenbank
abgeben
okay das wird lustig spannend so richtig
voll auf das richtige
und da ist der ak lebt denn es noch ja
denn es liegt sogar noch krass
junge mann findet einfach nur noch leere
kisten das kannst du nicht sein der
boxee box
ja ja ja ich bin ein bors alter geile
scheiße alter ich hab meine erste waffe
die ich finde es einfach der die axt
jung jetzt wird's mit rasiert
hoffentlich hoffentlich erwischt jetzt
ein mit guter rüstung dennig falten kann
da hinten genauso ein brauchen wir den
jannik 1 steht doch einfach mal legte ji
quan triffst du mit deiner scheiße läuft
warum halte was hat er für alles gilt es
mich verarscht während während technisch
veraltet der ist ein typ der will mich
grad richtig verarschen scheiße und
jetzt nicht etwas jetzt hat jeder hätte
ist gut jeder hättest punkt für mich
jeder hättest punkt für mich is back im
boden bekommt jeder held ist ein punkt
für mich nächste check wieso ich kann
warten du kannst nicht recken du kannst
nicht stehen bleiben
das ich habe ich damit gerechnet dass er
stehen bleibt
nikon hat den rafah ist der krieg schon
wieder ein herz ein herz ein herz ist es
ganz so eine seltsame situation alter
aber dieser johnny kann da nicht viel
leben haben ja der box sollen nicht
gestürzt ist einfach ganz ehrlich habe
jetzt keinen respekt für dich du musst
sterben so alles klar
begleitet hat ein gutes zeugnis alter
läuft weiter
ich habe auch ein gekillt so jetzt seid
ihr immer auf john da hinten mit dem
eisen schwert schon mal das thema
wechseln
kannst du mir sagen wo fg um mittels der
gute der gute johnny catwalks auch nicht
der bvb-profi alter wie viel leben
dennoch hat es mich verarschen kurve
schlechte ist hast du das gesehen hast
du gesehen wie schlecht er ist jung und
ich meinte ich werde sich überhoben
klingen oder abgehoben klingt aber wie
schlechte ist was ist aber ich scheiße
was ist im kampf alter und vor allem wie
viele für die bilder noch ein stück mich
überrascht gleich einer von hinten
halten
wir kommen hier raus nein nein wie und
plötzlich waren können kann man es hier
raus klatschen den fakten
nein noch leute wir machen kurzen kap
sehen uns dann wieder wenn ich auch aus
gekommen bin und ich mache einfach so
ein speed lauf hin
da drüben sind die schalter er geht
einfach weiter oder er macht tnt
okay das hat mir genau null schaden
gemacht meckerte relativ fit for life
alter fit nicht mehr junge leute ja ihr
habt die szene wahrscheinlich gerade
schon mitbekommen
ich bin wieder draußen ich hatte eine
aus gerettet und hat nebenbei noch mit
dem feierlich die wand geschossen aber
so hat keine ahnung also entweder du
geile hacks oder was anderes ich weiß es
nicht aber ich will gar keine aussage
über hacker in einem video machen weil
davon hab ich aber zu wenig ahnung als
dass ich da sagen könnte ja okay dass
hacker und der nicht auf jeden fall habe
ich jetzt aus sieben leuten sechs
gemacht und ich hoffe dass die leute die
ich jetzt gerade keinen team sind ich
habe sechs pfeile vieles parat gold
apfel ist parat
das sollte eigentlich laufen okay leute
es war auf jeden fall so lustig bisher
dieser eine typ der einfach nichts macht
er einfach da steht in die luft haut
wenn ich könig er schreibt hacker immer
gesagt puh ich bin ich mit dem sports
sports alte ich bin ich bin pünktlich
zum beispiel am spot- und achim aber die
sind also in diesen beiden interessieren
okay der sp am 5
rasenmähen als junge wie ich rasiere
alter gibt dir das man ich habe den voll
gegeben und es ist ein team zu drei abo
gegeben richtig geiler typ dem man ja
was ist das für eine fucking spielrunde
das läuft so übel gerade da machst du ne
slomo rheinmain.de das ist das video mit
20 findet ohne scheiß wir nehmen schon
ewig lange aufhören bisher nur elf
minuten plus drei minuten oder so zimmer
noch ab okay mein alter ok hat sie hat
sie jetzt leute feiner find ich hab noch
nie eine 64er runde gewonnen komposch
stieß der spam ps3 wieder aussieht
ja ja ja das war geil is best of best of
64 ist mein erster 64er in und ich habe
direkt aufgenommen
while alter läuft okay leute wenn euch
gefallen hat dann lasst einen daumen
nach oben da ich glaube es war richtig
richtig geil ich habe richtig spaß
gehabt markenhändler max dennis also
total drei und wer ihm sind beide in der
beschreibung schaut euch die machen dann
ist es relativ gut im pvp das noch
unklar
wer würde sagen wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video wieder richtig spaß
gemacht ich freue mich aufs nächste
video macht es gut 30